this is a framed picture of the cat um
it's not my cat this is my daughter's
cat uh this this this is her pet just to
be clear but this is the frame picture
it's a nice frame it's not on the
bookshelf anymore she apparently put
that on the bookshelf behind me right in
the shot yesterday and I didn't notice
it until after I'd finished recording
the show so any eagle-eyed viewer on
Monday could have watched the show and
mistakenly come to the conclusion that
I'm the sort of man who keeps a framed
picture of the cat on his bookshelf I
think the glare from the light might
have saved me so I'm not even sure how
visible so I might just be outing myself
for this in a way that I didn't need to
um but if someone had seen that they
might have come to the conclusion that I
live some sort of double life like
publicly pretending to be relatively
normal while privately I'm some sort of
cat obsessed freak